l'image qui restera de la 84e finale de
la coupe de france de football entre
bastia et lorient n'a aucun rapport avec
le sport avant le coup d'envoi la
marseillaise a été sifflé par une partie
des supporters corses
une manière pour eux de manifester leurs
convictions indépendantistes une
attitude un en tout cas qui a provoqué
la stupeur l'indignation mais aussi une
belle colère de jacques chirac qui a
quitté la tribune présidentielle
antoine chuzeville philibert landau il
est 20h40 hier soir le speaker du stade
de france vient juste d'annoncer l'hymne
national
dans les tribunes les champs côtoient
les siffler tout au long de la
marseillaise notamment du côté des
supporters de bastia
jacques chirac mais quelques instants à
comprendre ça siffle je m'en vais
annonce-t-il au président de la
fédération dans la tribune officielle
c'est la confusion le président décide
d'interrompre le protocole demande le
renvoi des équipes aux vestiaires
jacques chirac exige également des
excuses immédiates de la fédération
oh
mais non
les joueurs reviennent sur le terrain
avec dix minutes de retard
mais jacques chirac demande une nouvelle
fois le report d'envoi les deux équipes
regagnent leur vestiaire
le président a décidé de prononcer une
déclaration en direct à la télévision
telles que six responsables ont cru
devoir siffler la marseillaise ce soir
au début de ce match
c'est inadmissible et inacceptable
je ne tolérerai pas et je n'accepte que
soit porté atteinte aux valeurs
essentielles de la république et à ce
qu'ils les expriment jacques chirac
refuse de saluer les joueurs avant le
début du match qui se déroule dans une
ambiance étrange après les incidents les
réactions sont très partagées
désolé je comprends pas parce que on se
doit de respecter
on ne peut pas compte que c'est
mais là c'est trop petit si c'est un non
lieu
c'est parce que l'état français montre
du doigt sans cesse le peuple corse
parce que ça les décors ces témoins
lancé hier par l'état le président ahmed
qui sent la ja vichy
du côté des joueurs bastiais battu 1 0
une fin de soirée teintée
d'incompréhension et de déception alors
je pense que le président n'aurait même
pas dû venir
pas du tout mais je pense qu'ils
auraient dû descendre et les mots serrer
la main on pensait tous malgré
l'embarras des instances sportives les
grands événements servent souvent
d'exutoire les supporters ne se gêne pas
pour y manifester plus ou moins finement
leur hostilité envers des équipes des
pays ou des individus les stades
deviennent des lieux d'expression et de
contestation et hier soir jacques chirac
ne l'a pas supporté